the process for making Parisian
macaroons hasn't changed much since the
18th century
but inside Chantal keone's Palo Alto
store there's a high-tech revolution we
are very traditional base business small
business but technologies help us to be
very competitive
enter PayPal the company is turning to a
group of small businesses like Chantal
Guillaume to help test beacon its new
hands-free payment system we're trying
to make the payments disappear for
people who want them to disappear about
the size of a pack of gum beacon offers
a slew of features for retailers it can
send messages to customers who use the
PayPal app when they come to your store
like a special offer or sale and if you
opt into the hands-free mode you don't
even have to take out your wallet just
walk right in the store focus on what
you want to buy and then when you're
ready to pay your name and face
disappears in the point-of-sale system
of the retailer and they just charge
your PayPal account Chantal Guillen has
been working with PayPal for about eight
months when the customer came in you
don't have to exchange any more credit
cards and that allowed to save us a lot
of time and to focus more on the
customer service PayPal hopes macaroons
are just the beginning it's currently
testing beacon in the US and Australia
with a wider rollout plan for later this
year